OUT THE SERIES AT HOME.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS HE DIDN'T
PANIC.
HE DIDN'T POINT THE FINGER AT
ANYBODY ELSE.
HE SAYS, I'VE GOT TO DO A BETTER
JOB.
THAT IS LEADERSHIP.
NOT ALLOWING GUYS TO PANIC AND
HE SET THE TONE.
>> Mike: THE CLIPPER FANS RIGHT
NOW, MARK, COULDN'T AGREE MORE.
GIVING A STANDING OVATION AS
TYRONN LUE IS EMPTYING HIS BENCH
AND CLEARING HIS BENCH WITH 2:57
REMAINING P.M. CLIPPERS BENCH
WILL COME TO AN END THAT MADE
NBA HISTORY.
THEIR CONFERENCE FINAL
APPEARANCE EVER IN NBA HISTORY
AND FIRST TEAM IN NBA HISTORY TO
OVERCOME DEFICITS IN THE PLAYOFF
YEAR.
UNFORGETTABLE PLAYOFF
PERFORMANCES.
PAUL GEORGE'S PERFORMANCE IN
GAME FOUR AND DOWN 22 AT
HALFTIME AGAINST UTAH AND ONE OF
THE GREAT COMEBACKS IN PLAYOFF
HISTORY BUT IT ENDS TONIGHT IN
GAME SIX.
INJURIES JUST TOO MUCH TO
OVERCOME WITH NO KAWHI